ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะผู้หญิงคะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันนี้วันเสาร์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 19 ค่ะวันที่
19 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือนมีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพต
565 ค่ะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีพ.ศตั้งครรภ์
565 ราคาปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
16:19 นาทีค่ะตอนนี้เวลา
16:19
นาทีนะคะผู้หญิงวันนี้เรามีนักเรียน
กี่คนค่ะวันนี้เรามีนักเรียน 1  2  3  4
5  6  7  8  9  10  10 คนค่ะเรามีนัก
เรียน10คนรุม
เด็ก
นักเรียนผู้ชายนักเรียนผู้หญิงทั้งหมด
10 คนขอแล้วนักเรียน 10 คนมีนักเรียนผู้
ชายกี่คนคะมีนักเรียนผู้ชาย 1  2  3  4  5
6  7  7  7 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนผู้ชาย 7 คน
นักเรียนผู้หญิงกี่คนคะมีนักเรียนผู้หญิง
1  2  3  3 คนค่ะมีนักเรียนผู้หญิง 3 คน
มีครูครูครูผู้ชาย
กี่คนคะ
ครูผู้ชาย
ไม่มีค่ะ
ครูผู้ชายไม่มีครูผู้หญิงกี่คนนะคะโปรผู้
หญิง
122 คนค่ะ 2 คนนะคะ
ครูหญิงโอวันนี้นะนักเรียนแข็งแรงดีไหมคะ
โอเคนักเรียนทุกคนพยักหน้าบอกว่าแข็งแรง
ดีไม่มีใคร
I ไหม
อะไรหรอกไม้มีนักเรียนใส่หน้าไม่มีแข็ง
แรงใช่ไหมคะใช่ขอให้น่ะพยักมากอาไม่อาย
ไม่มีอันนี้หัวนะคะสายหัว
สายหน้าหน้า
หัวนะคะนาหัวสีฟ้าสายหัวส่ายหน้าเหมือน
ไม่มีนะคะไม่มีไม่มีทุกคนแข็งแรงอ่ะแข็ง
แรงมากๆงูมีนักเรียน 10 คอนวันนี้ครูเอ๋
อยากรู้
ครูเอ๋มีคำถามใช่แล้วเหรอคะแต่วันนี้คำ
ถามครูเอ๋นะกูเห็นต้องขอโทษก่อน
ทำไมทำไมครูเอ๋ต้องขอโทษคะเพราะว่า
คนไทยน่ะชอบขามคำถามนี้แต่คนอเมริกาคน
ยุโรปคนญี่ปุ่นแก
โกรธไม่ถามไม่ถาม
แต่ไม่ชอบขอ
เอา 3 อะไร
คำถามคือ
อายุเท่าไหร่โล
[เพลง]
อายุเท่าไหร่ครูหญิงครูผู้หญิงอายุเท่า
ไหร่คะครูหญิงอายุ
37 ปีค่ะผู้หญิงอายุ 37 ปีครูเอ๋ถามครู
หญิงปีนี้ปีนี้ 2,000  22
ครูหญิงอายุเท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิงโอเคเนาะไม่
โกรธ
ไม่โกรธโอเคไม่โกรธครูหญิงอายุเท่าไหร่นะ
ครูหญิงอายุ
37 ปีโห
อุ้ยทำไมหน้าเหมือน 17 ปี
ขอบคุณค่ะน่าบอกน่า
17 ปีเวลาคาคู๋บอก
บอกนะคะผู้หญิงอายุ
37 นะคะ 37
47 ปีโต๋ถามอายุคนที่ญี่ปุ่นคนอเมริกาคน
ยุโรปเนี่ยไม่โอเคโหคนอเมริกาคนยุโรปคน
ญี่ปุ่นคนเกาหลีจะ R5 ๆแต่แล้วถ้าครูเอ๋
ถามแล้วนักเรียนบอกไม่โอเคไม่บอก
ได้ไหมครับได้ๆแต่แต่ครูหญิง
กับนักเรียนรู้ไหมอ่ะว่าทำไมคนไทยชอบขาม
อายุ
ครูหิงค์ผู้หญิงผู้อยู่ที่ค่ะผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงรู้สึกเรียนเนี่ยอยากรู้
ทำไมคนไทยถามอายุคะครูเอ๋คนไทยก็จะพูดพี่
พี่หาครูหญิงยังไม่ถามกูไอ้เลยเออใช่ขอ
โทษค่ะครูหญิงอายุ 37 ปีจบคุณค่ะครูเอ๋
อายุเท่าไหร่คะ
รู๋อายุ
54 ปี
54 คนแก่
โทรเอสเสจแก่กว่าครูหญิง
ๆครูเอกแก่กว่าผู้หญิงฉี่ปีคะ
ปิด 7 มั้ยอ่ะต่อไปค่ะ 17 ปี
ครูเอ๋แก่กว่านะแก่กว่าคู๋ยุมากกว่านะคะ
พูดแก่กว่าโอเค
พูดอายุมากกว่า
คู๋อายุมากกว่าครูหญิง
17 ปีนะคะ 17 ปีอะคู๋พูดโอเคเพราะว่าครู
เอ๋
ค่า 14 ด้วยน้าผู้หญิงคุณแม่คุณแม่ครู
หญิงอายุเท่าไหร่
อันนี้ครูหญิง
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ค่ะคุณแม่
อายุ
56 ปีค่ะคุณแม่ครูหญิงอายุ 4  56 ก็อายุ
ใกล้ๆครูเอ๋
คู่เอ๋แจง
[เพลง]
ลบ
สิบเจ็ดและครูเอ๋า
37 ก็ไม่ขี้นะ 17 ปีพี่ไม่ก็ได้น้าเอาใจ
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องพูดน้าเอ๋นะคะน้าเอ๋คนไทยนะ
มีพี่มีน้านะมีพี่พี่มีนะมีมีป้ามีมากๆก็
ต้องถามอายุข้าไม่ใช่บ้านเหมือนกันก็พูด
ที่เค้าเอ๋อายุ 54 ปีครูเอ๋พี่ผู้หญิง
อายุ 37 ปีผู้หญิงน้อง
พี่ผู้หญิงต้องสวัสดีครูเอ๋เอาเวลาครู
หญิงเจอครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะ
เพราะคู๋ 54 ไม่ต้องกลม
แต่ครูหญิงถ้าเป็นน้อง
ต้องก้มอมพระหัวเนี่ยกงแล้วก็ว่ายอันนี้
ก็สวัสดีค่ะ
Google นิดหน่อย
คนไทยถามอายุ
สำหรับใครว้ายใคร
ถ้าน้องไหว้พี่ชายนะคะใช่เพราะว่าพอรู้
ผู้หญิง 37 โฮ๋ 54 ผู้หญิงก็ไหว้ครูเอ๋
เพราะว่าตอนนี้บัญชีดูตาแล้วก็ดูหน้าไม่
เข้าใจอายุเท่าไหร่ทำงั้นก็ไม่รู้ใครพี่
ใครน้องก็ต้องถามอายุอะถามอายุค่ะวันนี้
ครูเอกก็ไม่รู้นักเรียนน่ะเป็นพี่หรือ
เป็นน้องครูเอ๋ครูเอกก็เลยต้องขอโทษค่ะ
ถามอายุนักเรียนหรือนักเรียนอายุเท่าไหร่
เดี๋ยวคู่หญิงอยู่นะคะจะถามเนาะนักได้เลย
ค่ะคุณเอ๋เพราะว่าครูเอ๋ 54 ตา
มองไม่โอเคไม่เช่น
ครูเอ๋บอกได้ครูเอ๋อยากรู้อายุใครครูเอ๋
อยากรู้อายุอายุใครดีอ่ะอายุนักเรียนใหม่
ขอคุณเขาคุณเขาคุณเค้าคะคุณเค้าอายุเท่า
ไหร่คะน้อง
ถ้าคุณเขาบอกว่าอายุเท่าไหร่คุณเขาบอกว่า
อายุ
40 ปีค่ะ
คุณเค้าอายุ 40 ปี
คุณเขาสวัสดีครูเอ๋
คุณเอ๋เป็นพี่
ผู้หญิงสวัสดีคุณเพราพอ
สวัสดีค่ะคุณเคล้าเพราะขลุ่ยน้อง
ไม่ได้สิ
ทำไมอ่ะครูหญิงเป็นน้อง
น้องสวัสดีพี่
แต่ผู้หญิงเป็นครู
คุณเรานักเรียนนักเรียนสวัสดีครู
โอเคสองคนสวัสดีกันได้
แต่ถ้าคุณเค้านะคะอายุเท่าไหร่นะคะผู้
หญิงคุณเค้าอายุ 40 ปีค่ะอ่าขอบคุณค่ะคุณ
เค้าคุณเขาบอกได้ต่อไปนะคะคะครูเอ๊ะถาม
ผู้ชายก่อนเนาะได้ค่ะขอโทษนะคะคุณแระอายุ
เท่าไหร่คะโอ้คุณแบรด์บอกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
คุณแม็กไม่ไม่ปิดนะคุณแมทท์หมดอายุโอเคนะ
คะโอเคคุณแม็คอายุเท่าไหร่คะครูหญิงคุณ
แบรด์อายุ
58 ปีค่ะ
คุณแม็คอายุ 58 ปี
คุณแร้คเป็นพี่พี่ครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะคุณแบรดพี่แบลสหน้า
ครูหญิงก็ต้องเรียกขี้เขา
พี่แบล็คพี่เอ๋
[เพลง]
พี่เขาหาก็มีพี่ผู้หญิงเป็นน้องนะคะทอน
ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิงครูเอ๋อยากจะรู้คุณ John
แท็กสั้นอาคุณ John เท็กซัสคุณ John แท็ก
ซาดคะอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณจอนบอกได้ค่ะครูเอ๋คุณจอนบอกว่าอายุ
เท่าไหร่คะคุณ John อายุ
42 ปีค่ะ
42 ปีคุณ John ไหว้ครูเอ๋พิ
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อะไรน่ะพี่แบงค์ที่แบรนด์ที่
บชขอ
คุณ John อายุเท่าไหร่นะ 42 นะคะจะไปฆ่า
ก็คือผู้หญิงก็ยังน้องหล่าผู้หญิงเป็น
น้อง
คุณโรเบิร์ตค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
ครูหญิงคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋บอก
ว่าอะไรคะคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่า
อายุ
36 ปีค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตอายุ
36 ปี
นะคะ
ผู้หญิงเป็นพี่
คู่ Day
ผู้หญิงเป็นที่แล้ว Robert เป็นน้องนะคะ
เอาเบอร์ต้องสวัสดีครูหญิงค่ะดีใจดีจะได้
กลับไปค่าครูเอ๋อย่าง
คุณเกาหลีคุณเท่ๆนี่อะคุณเชที่คนเทคะ
คุณเทพูดได้ไหมอายุเท่าไหร่บอกคุณเท
พยักหน้าค่ะออกได้อยากหน้าโอเคคุณเท
อายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณเธอบอกว่าอายุ
24 ปีค่ะครูเอ๋ออยู่ยี่สิบสี่ปีคุณเช
เด็กเด็กไหมอายุน้อยที่สุด
S คุณเชทีก็ต้องสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋เอ๋
สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดีนะครับพี่เค้า
สวัสดีครับที่ Black สวัสดีครับพี่จอน
สวัสดีครับพี่โรเบิร์ตเลย
เป็นน้องนี่เหนื่อยนะที่ประเทศไทยๆต้อง
สวัสดีครับทุกคนค่ะนี่พี่ก็สวัสดี
ไม่ต้องก้มก้มนิดหน่อยนะคะ
ผู้ชายกี่คนแล้วผู้ชาย 1  2  3  4  5 มี
อีก 2 คนค่ะผู้ชายโอเค
ผู้ชายสวีเดนออกคุณ John คุณ John สวีเดน
5 คุณ John สวีเดนคะค่ะอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณ John สวีเดนบอกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
แต่มันบอกว่าอายุเท่าไหร่คะครูหญิงคุณจอน
บอกว่าอายุ
34 ปีค่ะน้ำ 14 ปีผู้หญิงเป็นที่อีกแล้ว
โอ้ว
ผู้หญิงมี
คนคนอายุน้อยกว่าผู้หญิงกี่คนแล้วคะ
ตอนนี้มีคนอายุน้อยกว่าครูหญิง 1  2  3  3
คนค่ะครูเอ๋ก็เป็นพี่ของสามคนนะคะใครค่ะ
พี่คุณเทคุณจอนแล้วก็คุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ
John สวีเดนอายุน้อยกว่าผู้หญิงโอเคชาย
คนสุดท้ายคุณทาดาชิคุณ Thailand  Chic คน
คุณครูเอ๋ถามอายุ
ได้ไหมคะ
คุณทาดาชิพยักหน้าค่ะได้นะคะได้ยังไงคุณ
ทาดาชิคะคุณธาราชิอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณทาดาชิบอกว่าคุณทาดาชิอายุ
29 ปีค่ะอายุ 29 ปี
อายุน้อยกว่าครูหญิงถ่ายผู้หญิงดีใจเย้
นะคะ
เหลืออีก 3 คนใช่ไหมคะเออกันนักเรียนผู้
หญิง
นักเรียนผู้หญิง 3 คน
ผู้หญิงถามอายุได้ไหมคะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋ได้
ยินว่าผู้หญิงเกาหลีผู้หญิงโป้ญี่ปุ่นผู้
หญิงอเมริกาผู้หญิงยุโรปโป้ผู้หญิงใกล้
หวันห้ามถามอายุเท่าไหร่โตไม่ได้ไม่ได้
แต่ครูเอกก็จะไม่รู้จะพูดพี่หรือน้อง
แต่รู้พี่น้อง
ครูเอ๋แต่นักเรียนเราผู้หญิงผู้หญิง 3 คน
พยักหน้าบอกว่าถามได้ค่ะถามได้นะคะขอบคุณ
ค่ะคุณประวีณาก่อนแล้วกันคุณประวีณาคุณ
ประวีณาอายุเท่าไหร่คะคุณประวีณาบอกแล้ว
ค่ะครูเอ๋คุณปวีณาบอกว่าอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณประวีณาบอกว่าอายุ 26
ยินดีค่ะ
26 ปีเด็กๆถึง
สวยนะคะ
ก็น้องครูหญิงน้องครูเอ๋นะคะค่ะมันต่อไป
ค่ะคุณ
คุณลิซ่า
คุณลิซ่าอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
คุณลิซ่าบอกแล้วค่ะอาบอกว่าอายุเท่าไหร่
คะคุณลิซ่าบอกอายุ
31 ปีค่ะครูเอ๋ปี
[เพลง]
น้องครูหญิงน้องรู๋นะคะคนสุดท้ายคน
อเมริกา
คุณคนแค่ถ้าคุณแค่ยิ้มค่ะกินเขาบอกโอเค
บอกได้ร้านคุณแคทขาคุณแคทอายุเท่าไหร่คะ
ก็คุณแคทบอกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋ยกแล้วคุณแคท
บอกว่าอายุเท่าไหร่คะคุณแคทบอกว่าอายุ
27 ปีค่ะ
อายุนิดหน่อยนะคะฟ้อง 17 ปี
ผู้หญิงทั้งหมดเนี่ยใครอายุน้อยที่สุด
คุณแตฮี
อายุน้อยที่สุดค่ะคุณตายอายุน้อยที่สุด
ใครอายุมากที่สุด
คุณแรสอายุมากที่สุดค่ะแบรด์อายุมากที่
สุดมีคนอายุเท่ากันไหมไม่
ไม่มีไม่มีคนอายุเท่ากันไม่มี 40  40 วัน
นี้ไม่มีไม่มีใครอายุใกล้ๆกันบ้างคะใกล้
กันใกล้กันก็ครูหญิงกับคุณโรเบิร์ตอายุ
ใกล้กันขอครูหญิงอายุเท่าไหร่นะคะครูหญิง
อายุ
37 ปี
คุณโรเบิร์ตอายุเท่าไหร่คะคุณโรเบิร์ต
อายุ
36 ปีอายุ 36 ปีอายุใกล้กาดการแล้วก็มี
ใครอีกคุณประวีณากับคุณแคทก็อายุใกล้กัน
อายุใกล้กันห่างกัน 1 ปีนะคะ 1d ค่ะผู้
เรามีนาจมีอายุใกล้ไกลกันค่ะนี่ใครเป็น
พี่คนโต
ในห้องนี้ใช่ไหมคะให้คุณคุณแบรคเป็นพี่คน
โตใครเป็นพี่คนที่สอง
ครูเอ๋เป็นพี่คนที่ 2 ตัวเองเป็นพี่คนที่
2 ใครเป็นน้อง
น้องคนเล็ก
คุณแตฮีตอีเป็นน้องคนเล็กเขาไว้ 5
อายุน้อยที่สุดอายุ
อายุ 24 ปี 24 เป็นน้องคนเล็กนะคะเมื่ออา
ผู้หญิงอยากถามอะไรนิครูหญิง
อยากถามครูเอ๋เอ๋มีอยู่ในนี้เนี่ยครูเอ๋
อมีคนเป็นพี่พี่ครูเอ๋เอ๋กี่คนเป็นพี่ครู
เอ๋หรอหรอกูเห็นดูแล้ว 1 คน
คุณแบรด์คุณแม้เป็นพี่ครูเอ๋
1 คนค่ะมีคนเป็นแล้วพี่คนเป็นน้องครูเอ๋
กี่คนคะผู้หญิงมีคนเป็นน้องครูเอ๋ 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  8  9  10
10 คนค่ะเป็นน้องครูเอ๋ขอขอบคุณคุณแม็ก
ที่เป็นพี่ฮ่าๆๆแล้วมีคนเป็นพี่ที่ครู
หญิงกี่คนมีคนเป็นพี่ครูหญิง 1  2  3  4
มี 4 คนค่ะบ่นมีคนเป็นน้องครูหญิงกี่คนคะ
มีคนเป็นน้องครูหญิง 1  2  3  4  5  5  6
7  7 คนค่ะ 7 คนเป็นน้องครูหญิงอาคารท่อ
ท่อโอเคนะอันนี้นักเรียนตอบครูเอ๋ขอบคุณ
นะคะนักเรียนบอกอายุให้ครูเอ๋รู้คู๋จะได้
รู้เรียกพี่หรือน้องงูจ่ายครูเอ๋ก็ต้อง
เรียกพี่แบ๋ I ข่า Grand เราผู้หญิงหญิง
ทำไมคะครูหญิงเรียกพี่เอ๋พี่เค้าพี่แบรด
พี่จอนหมดแล้วค่ะไม่มีพี่ถ้าไม่มีหนี้คุณ
โรเบิร์ตเป็นน้อง 1 ปี 5
น้อง taekey น้องจอนน้องทาดาชิน้องประ
วีณาน้องลิซ่าน้องแคทนี้เป็นน้องครูหญิง
แล้วคุณแตฮีต้องเรียกทุกคนว่าอะไร
กุญแจทุกคนว่าพี่
คุณแบรดเรียกทุกคนว่าอะไรคุณแรกเรียกทุก
คนว่าน้องพอดีไหมนี่เนาะคุณแรสนี่โอ้ว
เป็นพี่พี่ทุกคนเป็นพี่นะคนไทยนะคะถาม
อายุเท่าไหร่จะได้รู้
ใครที่ที่ใครน้องๆนะคะแล้วก็จะได้รู้ว่าย
หรือไว้นะ
ครับพี่ก็สวัสดีน้อง
คุณเต้เนี่ยเป็นน้องอะไรก็ต้องสวัสดี
ครับพี่สวัสดีครับพี่สวัสดีครับพี่สวัสดี
ครับ
ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋คุณเซฮีเนี่ยเป็นน้องเวลาเจอ
ทุกคนคุณเตดีต้องสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋เอ๋
สวัสดีครับพี่แบรดใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะ
ต้องสวัสดี 1 คน 1 คน 1 คนเหนื่อยจริงๆ
เหมือนครูเอ๋บอกคุณใจเฮต้องสวัสดีคนแรก 5
เป็นคนแรกมันครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋เอ๋หน้าเห็น
หน้ากันครูเอ๋ 54 ผู้หญิง 37 คู่เอกก็แตะ
อีกแล้ว
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องหญิงมีแต่จะ
ไม่นะเจอหน้ากันแล้วถ้าเหสวดีค่ะครูหญิง
โอเคมั้ยไม่โอเค
โอ้ยใหม่หรือไม่ได้กูเองเป็นพี่ผู้หญิง
เป็นน้องไม่ได้ไม่ได้ได้ไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะไป
ค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็เข้าใจ
ทำไมคนไทยถาม
อายุเท่าไหร่นะถ่ายไม่โกรธคนไทยและไม่
โกรธอ่ะไม่โกรธนะคะสายส่วนวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลาน้องครูหญิงกับครูเอ๋ก็ต้องน่ารักๆไป
แล้วนะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ